today's topic Amber Geiger has just been
sentenced to ten years in prison
well people are like surprised she only
got ten years in life oh my god it's
just ten years I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not surprised
I'm not surprised you get ten years
people are surprised like oh my god it's
like people never freaking learn but
it's just like to me it's just like a
school shooting you know when there's so
many school shootings and you're like Oh
DJ Khaled and another one I'm not
surprised that it's just ten years I
called it they suggested who was right
I think the justice system did its job
but unfortunately for most people that's
not enough no and it's really by a
cumulation right what do you mean by
that it's not just this case is the
other case of nothing happened and the
other kids and so it's just the
accumulation of [ __ ] that was not going
on and then this one so it makes it even
worse I'm not surprised by this Verta
did call it I did call the sentence on
and the reason being is that's pretty
close to the standard for police
officers who are grossly negligent and
kill somebody so you had the case of mr.
Noor the Somali police officer who
killed a white woman in Minneapolis or
was in Minnesota and when he did that he
was sentenced to 12.5 years he was in
his car there's girl rolled up at the
window he was scared or fear for his
life I'd he accidentally shot her then
you have the guy who killed
laQuan McDonald in Chicago he was
sentenced to seven years so you know
that's around the range that I expect
from most of these cases there's no way
that they could have given her 20 28
years lived life 19 and there's no way
it would have been overturned in no time
because you cannot justify that sentence
based off the standards that they have
set well and I'm not saying she didn't
deserve 25 I'm saying that according to
the story that happened in the past 25 I
had a few problems with this case and
even some of the defense around it
because I think when you realize it
police officers are just not held to a
very high standard I think that is the
biggest problem you know at least
especially for America me having lived
there for some time dealt with them you
you realize that their practice
are more rooted in their own personal
safety than the safety of whether
citizens on one hand you know they said
that Geiger came off of overtime she was
really tired and therefore that's why
she ignored the rent mat that was in
front of both UM's apartment which is
not in front of hers that's why she
ignored the furniture inside the
apartment which it doesn't look like
hers right the reason why she did that
it was because she had overtime and she
was tired okay
first off you signed up for that job so
you have to make sure that you're ready
to take on that job regardless and if
you're not then don't take the overtime
the second thing is she didn't follow
protocol which really bothered me okay
because here was someone she said she
thought it was a burglar and what she
did was break every police protocol that
they had in place which is why they
fired her and her defense team said oh
she's off duty therefore she doesn't
have to follow police that's not how it
works in that when you're a peace
officer
you're a peace officer 24/7 I know this
because a peace officer even when he's
off duty can still arrest you they still
have all the exact same judicial powers
that they normally have when they're on
duty so if you have that power all the
time then you have that same
responsibility all the time what'd he
say and so if you don't follow the
protocol and then you're negligent and
that results in someone's death then yes
I have a huge problem with that that is
extremely dangerous that you didn't do
what you were supposed to which is back
off call for backup and then approach
the person because of overtime and
that's after the work imagine what it
would be if she was at work that's a
good point
my second point is it is forgiveness but
black people can be the most forgiving
people and they can be the most
unreasonable people like the spectrum -
yeah same time and like myself what
youth or how much you've taken from us
I think you know that but I just
[Applause]
I hope you go to God with all what all
the guilt all I think the bad things you
may have done in the past each and every
one of us may have done something that
we're not supposed to do if you truly
are sorry I know I can speak for myself
I I forgive you and I know if you go to
God and ask him he will forgive you
and I don't think anyone could sit again
I'm speaking for myself not even bad for
my family but I love you just like
anyone else and I'm not gonna say I hope
you rot and die just like my brother did
but I see I personally want the best for
you and I wasn't gonna ever say this in
front of my family or anyone but I don't
even want you to go to jail I want the
best for you
isn't that from an Adele song never mind
I'll find someone like you I wish
nothing but the best for you even though
you give my brother gee I can't believe
I'm sorry and I'm I'm having a hard time
listening to this man with a straight
face I don't know if this is possible
but can't can I give her a hug please
please
I can't watch anything bro this is a
whole other topic the god thing is great
to forgive it's great to forgive and
forget but no I don't know no no you
know no hey you lost me brah you don't
do drugs you don't do none of that
you make sure you do the best you can do
just to beat you you live your life get
out of my house you pay for your
apartment you stand this is it you're
doing your thing then police enters in
your house to shoot your ass in your
house and I have to forgive you somebody
y'all are gonna be like hey you know
what he's the bigger person I think it
ain't got nothing to do a size I think
it's okay not to forgive someone and to
turn the other cheek and I can't with
that sentence
I mean you kid you wanna kill my dad
well now I gotta turn the other cheek
and present to you my mom you know but
you know you but you didn't let me kill
your mom do you gotta turn you the cheek
and eventually got no more cheeks left
to turn you just lips I can't look at a
video in just of his intentions all I
can say is me
I'm keeping both my cheeks that's what
I'm saying
yeah now oftentimes forgiveness is for
the person who is suffering and so I
can't tell this young man how he should
handle his forgiveness that being said
when you're seen holding the hands and
and hiding the person who killed your
brother what that indicates to me is
that this person was given the
opportunity
to feel relief for their mistake their
deadly mistake before they've actually
suffered true consequences that being
that being said I have a because even
when the shark Charleston shooting
happened like a kid lost his mom in that
shooting and he got up then he's like a
Dillon I forgive you for killing my
mother I'm sorry but me I can't you
maybe he's a bigger man maybe I don't
know but me I just could I could accept
that somebody can rehabilitate
themselves I can accept that they maybe
have a second chance I'm fine
but hugging all that stuff what it means
to me personally is it almost D values
of life because I know if I kill
somebody their family members are just
gonna hug me if the courts gonna give me
a more lenient sentence because
everyone's on that kumbaya train and
this is specially resolved reserved for
black people because when I see this big
forgiveness train it just seems like
oftentimes it's black people always
forgiving other people for killing their
kids and their family members and that
to me is the problem I have with it and
I wish something bad for somebody ok
walk away from them when you hug in and
you say oh you don't even do I don't
even want you to go to jail do you know
what happened to society if everybody
followed people would hug you in jail in
court say thank you I'm not going to
jail then afterwards go kill off
somebody else no people have to learn
from those mistakes what she did was
grossly negligent I don't want her to
suffer because it makes me feel good I
want her to suffer because I won't
understand the consequences of that I
want society to see what happens when
you kill somebody right and we need that
because without that understanding while
you may be a good person not everyone
out there is black people the reality is
no matter what the sentence would have
been you guys would have been displeased
yes because you you realize that
whenever these cases happen black people
you know they pile up all the in
justices that have happened in America
and then they have this story that's the
latest thing and they feel like oh
finally maybe we're gonna get something
that but there's too much there's too
much that we haven't dealt with beneath
that this was never gonna be enough
yesterday it would have been right
right and you have to ask yourself
honestly if she would had a death
penalty would you felt any better today
I don't think you would have and you
know even though she was sentence in ten
years it's gonna be five years with
parole
yeah tax is not doing it's not doing two
years in Texas you have to do 50% year
sentence before you're illegible and
she's not gonna be in djenne population
all you people hoping that something's
gonna happen to her that's not gonna
happen right just like laQuan McDonald's
police officer killed him and was
sentenced to seven years they got good
and a cushy you know the cushiest prison
possible yes same things gonna happen to
her so you know she's gonna do her five
years and she's gonna go into protective
custody you're never gonna hear about
her again and that's the reality this
situation it is what it is I don't know
what do you guys think leave your
comments below do any other thoughts you
want add anything you want to say no
whatever yeah we're done here yeah you
sure are you jazzing bad nah nah I was
like you know when you finish a video
sometimes you want a resolution but this
one just leaves a sour taste yeah it's
just song because there's nothing gonna
happen like I want to say something but
there's nothing like there's nothing
else to say like this no it would be
nice if there was like a nice ending to
this in the night but there's no way to
man a man died there's no way that could
be a nice ending to this no matter what
a man died people in the after the
sentence was given out people were in
the courtroom screaming no justice no
peace and I just want to make some clear
the justice that you guys are looking
for is never gonna be found the justice
system no this is about people and the
way we view each other this is about a
woman police officer who when she sees a
threat her first instinct is to shoot
before assessing the situation properly
she fears for her life someone dies that
is the trend with police officers they
fear therefore they have a justification
to kill and personally I don't think
fear is always the best thing to use
when making decisions in the Army right
just because someone looks like a threat
when you're in in a combat zone you
don't just get to shoot there's a whole
bunch of sips that we make sure you go
through why because we don't want you to
act off your instinct of fear alone and
I just wish that police
were held to a higher standard when it
came to their practices this is this is
a problem about how policing is done
this is a problem about how people
perceive blackness even on black people
and how we perceive blackness between
each other so this problem is far larger
than this and and I think looking
towards the justice system to fix our
problems between people and it's just
like LGBTQ people looking for acceptance
within laws I'm like no until people
accept you
the laws won't matter we have to do a
lot of work yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't see nothing